Євгенія моральд українська снайперка із
позивним Жанна Д'Арк на військовому
обліку жінка перебувала 10 років із
початком повномасштабного вторгнення
вона добровільно пішла з початку
утероборону а потім почала служити у
полку спецпризначення я про це подбала
що десь років тому я спеціально
закінчила військову кафедру отримала
звання офіцерське посвідчення знаючи що
якщо не дай боже буде війна я зможу
абсолютно без проблем приймати в ній
участь Утім Євгенія проти обов’язкового
військового обліку для жінок Я відверто
вам скажу я до цього ставлюся негативно
бо це має бути реально добровільний
вибір і все ж таки основна роль жінки -
це Берегиня Так це сім'я це народження
дітей на тобто не всім воювати і це
стосується чоловіків не всім воювати на
передку тому мене навіть ображав я
пам'ятаю коли там видавали повістки там
десь на пляжах чи дискусії про
військовий облік жінок точаться ще з
минулого року У грудні Міноборони
України оновили у перелік спеціальностей
який налічував понад 100 професій через
бурхливу критику список скоротили до 14
позицій для представниць цих професій
військовий облік мав стати обов'язковом
з 1 жовтня Але після нової хвилі критики
напередодні вступу закону в дію його
відтермінували ще на рік реалії цієї
війни а змінили дуже багато і ми з вами
побачили що багато жінок змушені
сьогодні рятувати життя своїх дітей і
вивозити їх за кордон і тут постає
питання між двома речами між тим що З
одного боку жінкам е певних професій
треба ставати на облік з іншого боку а
жінка І власне чоловік батьки
зобов'язані забезпечити право на життя
своїй дитині і рятувати її і держава
мусить гарантувати хоча б одного з
батьків виїзним за словами гани Маляр із
2014 року жодна жінка в Україні не
потрапила на фронт примусово у лавах
збройних сил нині працює понад 50 тисяч
жінок із них 38 тисяч безпосередньо
служать це один із найбільших показників
серед країн членів НАТО генеральний штаб
офіційно заявляв на одному з таких
брифінгів А що станом на сьогодні вони
не потребують збільшення кількості жінок
які знаходяться на військовому обліку
наразі в ЗСУ є потреба лише у трьох
спеціальностях фахівцях із медицини
радіотехніки та харчових технологій тому
перелік професій можуть знову
переглянути Міноборони і генштаб
виступає за те щоб жінки цих
спеціальностей могли ставати на
військовий облік лише добровільно аби
закріпити це профільний комітету в
парламенті вже працює над відповідним
законопроектом
ми проговоримо про обов'язковість для
деякі певних категорій
жінок і в тому числі ми тут говоримо
вірніше правильне не про жінок а про
перелік спеціальності встрів
військово-облікова спеціальність але
загальна зараз думка про те що
більшість була або може абсолютно по
всім спеціальностям для жінок
добровільно крім того Міноборони обіцяє
що всі жінки навіть військовозобов'язані
зможуть безперешкодно виїжджати за
кордон досі на обліку стояли лише жінки
які пройшли військову кафедру медики та
жінки які служили за контрактом Разом з
тим юристи наголошують що військовий
облік ще не означає мобілізацію
військовий облік це
те що ж людина особа жінка чоловік стиль
є На обліку у військкоматі у центрі
укомплектування і центр комплектування
знає що є у них
серед кандидатів бути мобілізованим є
така-то особа з такою-то професією
такого той віку з такими тобелячками і у
випадку чого вони можуть коли будемо
мобілізаційне завдання від генштабу
можуть викликати цю людину поїздкою і
вже призвати і вже її мобілізувати та
працювати до армії та для українських
жінок в армії Немає майже нічого
неможливого вважає снайперка Жанна Дарк
війна не має стать
тобто жінка як і чоловік може вправно
бути у будь-якій професії тут вже більше
там можемо звертати на якихось
фізіологічні якості Наприклад якщо там
жінка маленька то їй буде досить важко
бути колометницею бо його треба тягати а
якщо жінка така Ну трошки збита да тобто
сильна взагалі без питань
чесно я пишаюсь вашими жінками а жінки
України довели що ми не тільки борща
офігенно готуємо А ще із зброєю добре
можемо розуміти